psychology however
can take things to extremes
that is why it's so hard to call the top
when i went on true geordi about three
years ago i said look
bitcoin way overvalued all it is is
computer code
i think it's going to go down and it did
it went down to about
from 20 000 to 3 to 4 000. recently
it broke back above 20 000. now that's
called a technical breakout
and when something does break above an
old high
there's no limit as to how high
psychology could take it
so we saw it wham right up to 40 000
it's got as high as 44 000 today
could go to 100 i still think bitcoin is
worthless
this is psychology driving the market
it's a millennial bubble
but how high does it go in the meantime
because i think it's worthless do i sell
it short at forty five thousand at fifty
thousand
no i certainly do not because like i
said you never know how high it's going
to go
when psychology takes over let's roll
the clock back now
to holland tulip mania
hundreds of years ago people were
remortgaging their houses to buy
tulip bulbs tulip bulbs were more
valuable
than gold and that's just
the effects of crowd psychology if
people are interested in this there's
two books i read as a kid
and one is labon the crowd and the other
is
extraordinary popular delusions in the
madness of crowds
by charles mckay because when i got
interested in the stock market at 14 i
went down witness library
and ordered dozens of books on the
subject and i quickly learned
this is not a pure mathematical thing
it is a crowd psychology thing
and once you tune into that you can
learn
how to ride those trends and the other
thing i would recommend to people is
a book called the secrets for profiting
in bull and burn markets by stan
weinstein
i had that one read as a teenager i must
have read it about 10 times
and later in life when i was a top
producing stockbroker stan weinstein
guru actually started mentoring me over
the phone i was one of his corporate
clients
uh every time you know he called the
office because he was on wall street
week and that he was
this this big figure in that world all
the brokers are looking at like it like
in our stan weinstein's on the phone
there's also a forum
that discusses and puts out
stock selections based exclusively on
stan weinstein's
methodology and that is called stage
analysis.net of which i am a member
and i think the last thing i posted on
that was that
zoom had done a technical breakout
around the beginning of the corona i
didn't buy any myself
god i wish i had if you look at the
subscriber growth
in zoom numbers and the share price jump
i mean that is definitely a company that
is going places in terms of
revenue and earnings per share growth
which is which what drives
um companies values the short sellers on
gamestop
looked at the financials they hadn't
made money in years they're still losing
money now
so that valuation in the billions
had no resemblance to reality but these
things
are never a straight line the people who
buy them
on the hype end up just getting wiped
and these things have to return to the
fur market value
eventually that's called the efficient
market
hypothesis and the fur market value is
based on the
discounted cash flow and earnings
of everything that the company is going
to make in the future
and people say well look if the short
sellers are buying all the
you know the short squeezers are buying
all the shows how on earth
are the shows ever going to come down
what happens is the company can issue
more shows at any time
and they often do when share prices go
up that high
the insiders start to sell all of those
shares they can't believe their luck
they've got shares at almost zero
millions of them
and next thing it's gone from five to
what almost
50 and they're they're inside a shirt
believe me they are filing reports to
sell those shares as quick
as possible so these things are flashes
in the pen stock market
will always go back to a fair market
value
at some point but in the meantime
psychology
creates these huge swings
which if you can read the trends and
forecast the trends
you can capitalize on those swings why
do you think bitcoin is worthless don't
you think the concept of bitcoin and
having a currency that's
not able to be manipulated by the
federal government
or by billionaire hedge funds
billion dollar hedge funds don't you
think that's a good idea
absolutely i completely agree so
what is the value of a commodity
you know exchange value industrial value
portability transferability
now and supply so look at the value of
gold
you know there's only much so much
supply of gold in the world
look at the value of uh you know any
other precious assets
bitcoin has the flagship factor
but anyone could create a cryptocurrency
so the supply is potentially unlimited
for people creating cryptocurrencies
surely someone else can create a
cryptocurrency
with all the same exact same attributes
as bitcoin
the supply is potentially infinite it's
not something you're mining out of the
ground that industry is going to use
that has this actual value
and you know eventually the governments
will
capitalize on that um
weakness in cryptocurrencies
i believe to
[Music]
bring the values back down well yeah you
know i'm
i'm not a fan of the government i'm all
for
everything that you just said well i
just think that it's a psychological
bubble
created by millennials and perpetuated
by millennials
and it's going to have to come crashing
down at some point but right now it is
on a red hot side it's going to the moon
alice
yeah it's at like 42 000 last time i
checked i think it was just
insane yeah yeah and i mean i've even
talked to
you know lots of bitcoin experts and
they all say don't invest in it just use
it as something to you to
you know if you can do transactions with
it casually you know what i mean
not if you think about a lot of people
say
if you think about investing in bitcoin
just just picture yourself throwing it
away or lighting that money on fire
if you want if you wanted like if
somebody owes you some money for a
service and they
they happen to have bitcoin ask him to
pay you in bitcoin
but don't take a bunch of your money and
put it into there because it's basically
just like burning it
i saw that news story recently i think
it was the german authorities
arrested a fraudster that had like tens
of millions of bitcoin
and he wouldn't give him the password so
they can't access it
but they've kind of like done something
so he can't access it either
huh yeah yeah that's a cool thing about
bitcoin the government can't take your
money away no matter what you've done
yeah i like that